welcome everybody to the third talk of
the fall for math mornings so this time
we're happy to have Jesse to this it's
great yeah excellent
from the statistics department see one
of our Reagan faculty in statistics
going to get to talk about statistics of
the universe after statistics and I
wanted to say statistics is an old
subject it's got it's always a
connections to mathematics of course
because the study of data and how we
interpret and understand it and in
recent years there's these connections
of deepens and there's more a lot more
mathematics and computer science that
that is incorporated into what
statisticians do you know we have a
growing group called the data science
program that includes
this department and people from other
departments and so it's pretty exciting
and I hope you enjoy this is
gameplay-wise
thanks thank you and good morning
everyone it's great to see so many of
you here today indeed I'm going to talk
a little bit about this area called
Astro statistics and so as you might
imagine it's statistics for astronomy
astrophysics cosmology so statistics and
machine learning and computer science
and applied math are all needed to do
various things in astronomy especially
as the that we're collecting more and
more data the problems and the models
are becoming increasingly complex and so
the area of Astro statistics has formed
to help fill the void of statistical
methodology that that's needed to
address these scientific problems and so
some of the problems and Astro
statistics are related to things like
finding or detecting exoplanets so
exoplanets are planets orbiting stars
outside our solar system and once we
found some exoplanets how to
characterize and describe their
populations some other problems are due
with the large-scale structure of the
universe how can we pull information
from from that structure and understand
what's going on the physics of our
universe some problems are trying to
classify objects so is an object that we
see is it a galaxy is it is it a star is
it a quasar what is it
or even if we know it's a galaxy what
type of galaxy is it is it a spiral
galaxy is it some abnormal shaped galaxy
are they two galaxies merging together
that makes it a very distorted object so
there are lots of problems in in
astronomy astrophysics and cosmology
that require mathematical methods and so
what I'm going to talk about today is
one particular problem which is trying
to understand what the distant universe
looks like and so we're going to have to
in order to understand the statistical
methodology first understand a bit about
the data so I'm going to begin with an
overview of some some topics in
astronomy that's going to lead us into
how we get this particular type of data
and the the data are actually quite
quite unusual as we'll see and then once
we have the data how we can actually
produce a map so we can get a picture of
what's going on in the distant universe
and of course as I continue if you have
questions just raise your hand or shout
out your question so we're going to
begin with actually the whole discussion
is going to be trying to address a
question what does the distant universe
look like ok um the issue is that we
can't see the distant universe so we can
see some objects that are nearby but as
we move further away from the earth the
objects have to be very very bright in
order for us to see them so it turns out
that that we cannot see the distant
universe so so we should just go home
and forget it
we're never going to know what it looks
like of course that's not the answer
we'll get to how we connect
we figure out what's going on in the in
the region of the universe that's really
far away but first we have to figure out
what do I mean by really far away it
seems quite quite arbitrary so we have
to have some notion of distance and and
many of us are familiar with this
closest star to the earth
this closest star to the earth is what
does anyone know what that is
yep the Sun excellent yes the Sun is the
closest star to the earth and and so the
distant distance from the earth to the
Sun is one astronomical unit that's just
by definition that's just saying we're
going to define that distance as one au
that is approximately 92 million miles
maybe some of you in your physical
education classes have had to run one
mile right with a time you and maybe you
have to do it once a year so imagine
92 million of those so we we have miles
but we can also look at it using a
different a different unit of distance
and that has to do with how far light
can travel within a particular amount of
time so it turns out that the Sun is 8
light minutes from us so if the Sun
suddenly shut off
we wouldn't know it for 8 minutes ok so
that gives us a sense of distance to the
Sun but but we are also within this
larger object called the Milky Way
so our solar system is a part of our
galaxy our galaxy is the Milky Way and
and this is a side image of what the
Milky Way might look like so we have
kind of the center of the Milky Way and
then stars and star systems that are
orbiting and then lots of dust and
things it turns out that the Milky Way
is about a hundred thousand light years
across so from one end to the other it's
a hundred thousand light years so 1
light year is a
since that light could travel in one
year and and then actually astronomers
typically don't use the units of light
years typically what they use is
something called parsecs where one
parsec is about 3.26
light-years okay so so the hundred
thousand light-years across
is about thirty kiloparsecs across
approximately so if you ever talk with
astronomers they're going to likely
communicate distances in in parsecs
kiloparsecs mega parsecs Giga parsecs
depending on what what type of Astronomy
they're doing the our solar system so we
as part of our solar system are about
eight kiloparsecs from the centre of the
Milky Way okay so if you were ever to
see the center of the Milky Way that
would give us a distance about eight
kiloparsecs okay so if we move out a
little bit further the Milky Way is a
part of another group which is called
the local group which is a
gravitationally bound collection of
objects and within this local group we
have our Milky Way and then there's
another Milky Way type galaxy called
Andromeda and the distance then between
our Milky Way our galaxy and this Milky
Way type galaxy is about 2.5 million
light-years away okay so 2.5 million
light-years away is about 780
kiloparsecs okay so the distance between
Milky Way type sized galaxies we can say
on the order of hundreds of kilo parsecs
but we're going to actually be moving
further apart and we're going to be
talking about the units of distances
between between galaxies that are not
directly gravitationally bound and so in
this image we see a bunch of different
galaxies and the distances between
galaxies would be described on scales
megaparsecs okay so so that's going to
be the scale that that we're considering
and so we want to understand what's
happening in regions that are mega
parsecs away even even more than that
but the problem is that as is going to
be depicted in this picture so suppose
that we in the Milky Way are at this tip
so we're standing here and looking out
at the universe and we're just cutting
out a slice and within this direction
we're just picking out where the various
galaxies are so each point on this image
is a galaxy and so what happens is we're
here and then we start to move further
and further away from us and perhaps you
can see what's happening in this region
it seems like there are there's a
there's a denser collection of galaxies
but as we move further away it seems
like there are fewer galaxies within
that same that same amount of space
right so we have this problem that
either one it could be that there are
simply fewer galaxies further from us
that's one option or it could be that we
can only see the really bright galaxies
that are far away because the other
galaxies are not bright enough for us to
see them or detect them okay so it turns
out that the the second point is the
case and and the issue has to do with a
property of light so light as you may
have guessed is our source of
information about the universe we we
understand what's happening in the
universe due to the light that we're
detecting but the problem is that the
further away an object is the dimmer it
appears to us okay so the apparent
brightness so how we perceive the object
is proportional to its actual intrinsic
brightness which is the luminosity but
it's it's divided by the distance
squared so the further away you get the
dimmer and
jekt is going to appear okay so if you
if you ever take a flashlight and set it
down and then kind of step back and see
you'll see the light spreading out and
so it's getting it's getting dimmer when
you're further away so that's what's
happening with with galaxies as well
when galaxies are really far away they
seem very dim maybe so dim that we can't
even see that they're there there's
going to be another property of light
that's going to be important for the
type of data we're eventually going to
be looking at and and this property is
is that light gets red shifted or blue
shifted so what do I mean by red shifted
and blue shifted well if the source of
the light is moving away from us the
light that's emitted from that source it
turns out the wavelength gets stretched
so the wavelength gets longer if the
source of the light like this is moving
towards us the wavelength emitted the
wavelength of the light that's emitted
from those objects gets crunched and so
the wavelength gets shorter so we have
redshifted light and blue shifted light
this is actually something that we've
all experienced just driving around if
you ever hear a police car and ambulance
coming from behind you so the same thing
is happening with sound waves when the
ambulance is coming towards us it seems
very high-pitched right so that's
actually the sound wave is getting blue
shifted it's getting crunched and and so
it's it sounds very the the wavelength
gets shorter and so a higher frequency
but then once the ambulance passes it
kind of it kind of fades away because
it's getting red shifted the sound wave
is getting stretched okay so the same
thing happens on most sound waves as
light waves and it turns out that this
is going to be really helpful for us
so the redshift of an object so imagine
we have a galaxy some distance away it
turns out that we can figure out how
much it's been the the light has been
shifted
if we knew V so we can observe the light
so we know the wavelength of light that
we observe if we somehow knew the
wavelength of the light that's emitted
we can figure out the redshift
okay the redshift is going to be useful
for us because that's going to be a sort
of it's going to be a proxy for it for
distance if we know the redshift then we
have a sense of how far away the object
is from us in the universe okay so all
we need the take away from this is
really just that redshifts redshift
tells us about distance and we can see
it better in in this picture so redshift
cosmological redshift in particular is
important because objects are moving
away from us at an increasing pace so
it's accelerating the expansion of the
universe is increasing at is
accelerating and so the the 2011 Nobel
Prize in Physics was awarded to the
astronomers who were able to figure this
out and so for us what happens is so
imagine we have these two galaxies one
galaxy has emitted light but as time
continues the objects are moving apart
because this because space-time is
expanding and so the light wave begins
to get stretched so here you see that
the wavelength from peak to peak is a
particular length and then as time
continues so we see time increasing the
wavelength so from peak to peak is
further apart and then by the time that
light reaches this other galaxy the peak
to peak is even further apart okay so
this is cosmological redshift so the
redshift that's due
due to the universe expanding at an
accelerating rate okay so we see that
this picture again we're here
so the Milky Way's here and as we get
further away this is increasing redshift
this is a redshift of point one and
point two and we see on the right side
the units in are the distance in in
lightyears
so one billion light-years two billion
three billion and you see that even
within this space we we see a depletion
of galaxies again that's due to the
inverse square law of light and and this
is just highlighting if we look at the
observable universe we're at the center
here and the 3d region alright so what
do astronomers do since we can't see
objects that are really far away due to
the inverse square law well sometimes
what astronomers do is they simulate
data they make fake data and just work
with the fake data as if it's real data
so some of you may have seen pictures
like this before maybe maybe not but
this is our simulated universe this is
based on the the millenium simulation
and the matter or structure where we
would find galaxies is along the the
lighter regions and then where we see
the the darker regions those would be
cosmological voids so where there's
there's a lower density of matter okay
so this is great we on with these
simulations so with these these fake
data astronomers build in what they
believe to be the physics of the
universe run the simulation and get this
picture so they have a sense of what
does the large-scale structure of the
universe look like based on our best
guess at various physical properties but
we'd like to do a little bit better than
just looking at the fake data we'd like
to see what the the actual distant
universe looks like okay so so the
question that we asked the beginning
what
does the distant universe look like
problem we can't see things that are
really far away it turns out that there
are some objects that we can see that
are very far from us and these objects
are called quasars so we have this this
image here where this arrow is pointing
is a quasar all these objects that are
present some are our galaxies maybe some
nearby ones depending on what direction
we're pointing could be stars but just
from looking at this image we couldn't
tell how far away the objects are it
turns out using some other other data
they figured out that that is a quasar
so what is a quasar a quasar is so the
name quasar comes from quasi-stellar so
until the 80s it was believed that
quasars were just some interesting type
of store and and actually this would be
some exam or these would be some
examples of quasars they are super
luminous objects they are thought to be
the at the center of really massive
galaxies so at the center of really
massive galaxies we'd have black holes
these black holes if they start
accreting material so if there's any
loose gas or other sorts of substances
that might be nearby the black hole
starts to to kind of make those that
substance move really fast and it gets
extremely bright so a number of these
are artists renditions of what a quasar
is but that's real data
so these quasars are thought to have as
much energy coming from it as 1000 times
the energy output of our entire galaxy
and so it turns out again that these are
extremely bright and and because of
their brightness we're able to see
quasars that are very far away and
that's going to be helpful
for as we'll see we in our Milky Way
galaxy do not have a quasar which is
good but some some think that it so in
dromeda which we saw is a galaxy that
looks like the Milky Way that that at
the Milky Way and Andromeda are
approaching each other and we could get
our very own quasar in three to five
billion years we'll see we're not we're
not sure but but it could happen okay so
so why are quasars useful so this is
where we're going to start getting into
our data and the data are interesting
actually I find that the wit the novelty
of thought required to figure out that
this type of data would be helpful was
quite extraordinary
so quasars are great they're very bright
even better we have observations of
quasars but quasars are just point
sources at various distances right so
quasars just tell us about about what's
going on at that particular distance but
we want to know what's going on but
between us and the quasar and so it
turns out that if you imagine that these
little red dots here are quasars and
then this is like the simulation data I
showed you so this is just for
illustration purposes but the light from
the quasar travels through the universe
to to get to us right so somehow this
light coming from these very bright
objects travels through the region of
the universe that we're interested in
and it turns out that as it travels
through the universe it it leaves a
signature of the universe between us and
the quasar on the light that we measure
at this end so so let me say that again
we're we're somewhere over here we see
these quasars and we're measuring the
light output from the quasars okay so
each quasar gives us a
spectrum of light and that light
actually has a signature of the universe
I'm going to call it the intergalactic
medium the IgM the stuff the stuff
between galaxies the stuff between
galaxies leaves an imprint on the light
we get from the quasar so if we have
light from a quasar we know something
that's going along between us and the
quasar kind of amazing actually so let's
get another picture of what's happening
so we we see the moon maybe tonight
you'll look at the moon and if there's
any cloud covering you'll see that the
light coming from the moon is traveling
through the cloud it's the same sort of
idea that we're going to get from the
the quasars light it's going to travel
through neutral hydrogen that's going to
be the type of gas that were a substance
that we're going to be interested in so
imagine that this is our quasar it's
going to travel through the stuff of the
universe and we measure them the light
that's traveled through the stuff of the
universe okay so here I am showing you
two two spectra so what is a spectrum we
have the wavelength of light so we saw
some of those pictures where you have a
light wave the wavelength is a distance
B from peak to peak of the light so
along this horizontal axis
it's just how long that peak to peak
distance is and then the height is
intensity so so we have coming from the
quasar light of different wavelengths
and this is telling us about the
distribution of that light so here are
two different quasars that have been
aligned in a particular way so we see we
have a peak here in a peak here can can
anyone see a big difference between
these two spectra yes yes back there
you
yeah okay great so so we see these two
things and the big difference is that
somehow this one has a lot more going on
raise that that's what you're pointing
out like there are all these different
different lines so what this this
craziness is are dips so they're dips in
the amount of light coming from these
wavelengths from these two different
quasars it turns out what what what you
just pointed out is exactly what we need
in order to understand what's happening
along the line of sight of the quasar so
so how is that so well this is what
astronomers call the lyman-alpha forest
and i'm not sure why they call it the
lyman-alpha forest because to me it
looks less like a forest and more like a
bunch of grass right like like a meadow
so you might call it the lime oopsies
that lyman-alpha meadow but anyway they
call it the lyman-alpha forest and where
these dips happen where the dip happens
is where the light coming from the
quasar hits neutral hydrogen the neutral
hydrogen absorbs some of that light and
leaves an imprint with that dip right so
so at these different different
wavelengths the lights traveling through
it hits neutral hydrogen the neutral
hydrogen kind of eats up some of that
light and we get a dip and then the rest
continues along the neutral hydrogen
eats some of the light and we get a dip
so this is helpful for us because we see
the observed wavelength where these dips
happen so this is actually going to be a
hard question I mentioned it in an
earlier slide but does someone recall or
can you think of another property of
light that's going to be helpful here so
this is tough
yes go and again yeah yeah
it's a yeah so you're you're hinting at
exactly what's going on so on it's
travelling a certain distance is what
you said and and that's right so the
lights traveling it gets absorbed and
then you eventually we're going to
observe the light at one end but but
what else is going on the light is
giving redshifted as it travels a
particular distance so we observe where
a dip happens it turns out that since we
can observe where the dip happens in our
so we we once we get the light we see
the observed wavelength but that over
observed wavelength has been red shifted
and so we know that where the dip
happened and we actually know something
else we know the property of neutral
hydrogen that causes that dip so we know
that that dip should have happened at a
particular wavelength and so because of
that we know the wavelength that should
have happened at and where we observe it
so we know the redshift we know how far
away that neutral hydrogen was in order
for us to say there's this amount of
neutral hydrogen at this spot so it's
due to properties of neutral hydrogen
and due to redshift that that we can
actually get along the line of sight how
much light was was eaten which tells us
how much neutral hydrogen there is okay
so it's kind of kind of tricky but but
again here's another picture so the
lights coming the light gets absorbed
and I'd like it's absorbed so what we
actually observe are these regions where
the light is absorbed and then we can
kind of back up and go back to where
that that cloud or where that neutral
hydrogen was so let's look at a little a
little movie here so this movie
is the light traveling from the quasar
it's going through various regions of
gas so we have the quasar distribution
of light and we see these lines
appearing and so the whole spectrum is
getting red shifted as the light travels
and so where these dips occur is where
there is more neutral hydrogen and then
eventually we're going to observe the
final spectrum so I'm going to play it
again just because it's a quick video
okay so the light traveling from the
quasars is going through the
intergalactic medium it's hitting
various clouds at some point we're going
to see it goes across a galaxy which is
going to produce an even bigger dip but
but basically so there's that big dip
which is right here so where these dips
happen travel along with the spectrum
and because of that we can get the the
amount of neutral hydrogen that's
occurring at that at a particular
distance okay
all right so so what else do we have
here so we have these different quasar
spectra from these quasar spectra this
one for example has a whole bunch of
dips in it it's traveled through a a lot
of neutral hydrogen and and so it's a
very very distant quasar given that it
must have encountered quite a bit of
neutral hydrogen so some of the
statistical challenges then with using
this type of data is we only know what
the observed quasar spectrum looks like
but we have to know how much neutral
hydrogen was absorbed in order to so we
have to know the original spectrum in
order to know how much was absorbed so
there's a statistical problem that I'm
not going to address but that's but
that's there and it's to to estimate
what the unabsorbed quasar spectrum
looks like alright so so we have we have
now this way of understanding what's
happening in the intergalactic medium we
can we can figure out what the
distribution of neutral hydrogen looks
like along the line of sight of a quasar
and we also have data on it and so
that's always nice so what we have in
this plot are if we were to pick a bunch
of different directions in the universe
so looking up at the sky on here so they
don't look like points but these are
actually points that that indicate where
a quasar is okay so we look in a
direction and if it's black in that
direction then that means there is a
quasar somewhere in that direction okay
so I'm going to cut out this red region
here and we're going to take a closer
look at what's happening in that region
and so I cut out this region and this is
just showing where we would have data
it's telling us within that direct
so that's this RA in Dec so on the on
the bottom of this plot that's the
direction we're pointing and then these
lines are the lines of sight that have
have observations of the amount of
Deuter hydrogen in that particular
direction okay so so I cut out this
little cube and I just plotted what the
data look like so at each point on this
line we have an estimate for the amount
of neutral hydrogen all right and so
this just shows you if we were just to
look at the top down we have these
collections or this collection of points
we can also consider cosmological
simulation data that's of that same
volume so I said that sometimes
astronomers like to look at fake data we
can look at fake data of the same volume
as our real data and do a comparison to
see if our real data and fake data are
looking if they look similar alright so
you can imagine lines of sight going
through the simulated data I'm just
going to jump through okay so this is
the the figure I want it to get to so
now that we have lines of sight from the
quasar so we have particular locations
here and now I've colored it according
to the amount of neutral hydrogen so we
could just say these are observations so
this is looking at a slice and then this
is looking at the line of sight we could
just say okay we're done we have our
picture of what the distant universe
looks like does anyone here think that
this would be sufficient like just this
kind of dotted picture of what the
universe looks like right yeah I see
some shaking heads like it would have
would have been the news you say that
you heard that there was some
astronomers have a picture of what the
distant universe looks like and that's
what they gave you
who would not be happy with that right
yeah so we want to somehow say okay we
have this data great we have data but
but what can that data tell us about
what's going on between the points or
within the 3d cube can't campus data
inform us about the the regions where we
don't have data and so that is where
statistics can come in right so with
various statistical methods we can
figure out ways of kind of coloring in
this map right we want to say I don't
have data here but I have data around it
and I want those points around it to
tell us something about what's happening
between it
okay so statistical methods can be used
in order to do that and so but the
problem is that when we start using
statistical methods we have various
choices that that need to be made and
some of the the choices are one with
what method do we use right there are
different ways of coloring in the the
empty regions and so this is to
illustrate one one way of estimating
what's going on between the the places
where we have observations so suppose
the this is our these are raw data so
I'm just looking at a a 2d slice of the
universe so we we pick some directions
and fix a distance and what we can do is
say that certain regions are going to be
something like averages of its
surrounding region okay so so if this is
our data we might say so we see kind of
a blue spot here that spot is the same
as this blue spot which is this blue
spot and so forth and we're just going
to start kind of averaging over where
our data are and we can do other things
with it but but for our purposes just
imagine that we're going to say the data
are some sort of local average of the
the surrounding observations okay so so
if we make the surround the kind of
neighborhood size bigger and bigger we
see that we start to lose the the
features in our data and we could end up
with with something that's really not
that revealing about the structure of
the universe so so we have different
different options different amounts of
smoothing that could be done
does does anyone have a sense of which
one of these looked looks the best all
right you again yep okay so number one
it you think that looks the best so this
is the raw data and and so that that can
be great as well it's just our actual
raw data it's going to have a lot of
missing observations so we're going to
want to do some some degree of smoothing
to also reduce the the affective noise
but but that's great okay so this one
does anyone like this one the best you
like it the best why do you like it the
best ah okay so you like the smoothness
of it okay that make that's great yeah
so this one's appealing like it looks
nice and smooth because it could be that
this is all noise it could be that the
structure that we see here is just noise
and so actually more smoothing is it
could be better does anyone like this
one the best no oh yeah so so anyway
there there's there are some decisions
that have to be made it turns out that
in practice we don't just pick the one
we like the best
but but there are ways of deciding what
level of smoothness what what properties
what parameters should be used for the
statistical modeling but it's good to
have a sense of what you think should be
going on so if you think that the data
are just full of noise you might think
then that you should have more smoothing
and so when you when you use various
statistical methods you should you might
expect
to see a higher degree of smoothing okay
great so this is not something that we
need to understand I I need under I need
to understand it but but we don't my
point is just that these pictures here
we're not just arbitrarily designed but
but actually there's there statistical
models that can be used in order for us
to figure out a good way of representing
the maps that that are produced of the
distant universe okay so so again don't
need to understand this but I just want
to show you that there is actually some
some equations that that come into play
for this sort of thing and at the end
this is what our simulated data will
look like would look like do look like
after selecting the appropriate amount
of smoothing okay so this is simulated
data and the writer regions are where
there's more neutral hydrogen and the
bluer regions are where there's less
neutral hydrogen okay and we can look at
just a slice so imagine if I took this
cube and cut through it this is what we
see and because it's just it's an
estimate when you do statistics there's
there's uncertainty that's present and
so this is the upper bound on the values
here and this is producing a lower bound
on the values here so so actually you
can imagine each slice is X is expected
to be somewhere between the upper and
lower bound and this is our best guess
at what that looks like yes exactly
yes yes so this would be a 68% interval
exactly yes yeah one standard deviation
plus and minus yeah so it they don't
look that different because we have a
lot of data but but when I look at this
every time I look at this I just see a
running man do you see the head and then
the arms and then the legs like he's
kind of like yeah so I can't not see it
but uh so so there he is
all right so so that was simulated data
now if we look at our real observations
this is what we get
so because we had more data with
simulated data cuz it's fake data and we
can you know produce a lot of it we get
this but once you start working with the
real data we don't have as many
observations so just to illustrate so
what we're looking for is a map that
that describes the distribution of
neutral hydrogen so our picture of the
distant universe and one is straw
actually he's a cosmologists one
cosmologists said that because of we
only have a certain number of quasars it
would be like trying to produce a map of
the United States only using seven
cities so that's the sort of amount
number of quasars that we have filling
the the region of the universe we're
interested in but we can still we can
still get these maps and so on with the
real data this is the fit and then on
the lower bound so minus the standard
error and then plus a standard error so
that this is our best guess of the
distribution of mutual hydrogen and the
and if we want it instead to look at it
interval it'd be somewhere between this
one and this one so we see there's a lot
more noise present with the real data oh
yeah
okay so great yeah okay great great
question so the question is what does
this even what does it even mean to have
this standard error
so so what happens with with data so
I'll just I'll speak generally and then
I'll come back to this when you have
data there's a certain level of of
uncertainty that's present right so
there's some some randomness in our data
and so we can we can estimate what we
think to be for example the true mean so
imagine that this is just our term mean
of this particular region of the
universe but if we had observed a
different data set we could get a little
bit different of a picture in in the
data and and if we observed another data
set we would had an even different
another different picture and so so what
this is trying to capture is that if we
had different data sets and we did the
same thing so if I produce this fit
using a bunch of different observations
which we don't have but you could
imagine that if we did have it that that
68% of you know the many many many sets
of data that we have
68% would produce maps that are between
this lower bound and upper bound
does that make sense are there other
questions about this so so often in
statistics we don't just give one one
number one value but but you have some
some degree some maybe you've heard
terms like margin of error and things of
that nature so so that's trying to
capture the uncertainty that's that's
present in in our best guess so new data
sets would produce slight fluctuations
yes oh yeah yeah
systems you can use use that level of
uncertainty and yeah so it's a great
question okay so the question was if we
wanted to produce a picture of the
United States and indeed we only had
seven spots to do it
I could I could give you a map now the
the issue is if we chose for example
seven different locations the map could
change quite a bit and seven other
locations I know change quite a bit but
but at least with the United States we
would have we'd be able to compare it to
a very dense map and so we could compare
it to to the truth with um with
something like the United States the
problem with the distant universe is
that we don't have a way to get more
observations so this just ends up being
our our best our best guess given the
data that we have so we we could try in
certain regions to get data using other
methods maybe maybe we can see some
galaxies in those regions and get a
sense of what's happening
the problem is any other sort of data
would not tell us as much about the
amount of neutral hydrogen which is what
this is revealing so let me let me come
back to that in one second and this is
actually so so I'm actually here not not
using the full data but just a small
piece of it and so so actually this is a
more recent just surface of a so I'm
cutting out a certain distance and then
just changing the direction and and so
this this particular image was produced
by Colin Eubanks from Carnegie Mellon
he's a stat PhD student and he's using
actually new and increased in new and
more data and and so he's able to get
this picture
and he's actually using some different
statistical methods than what I was
talking about that help to adapt to the
the design of the data a little bit
better and can produce a better picture
yep yeah so yeah so what we're actually
seeing are the the fluctuations from the
the average amount of neutral hydrogen
so we don't have we don't have like the
exact number of atoms but we just know
how much it's changing from an average
across the region of the universe so the
redder regions would just say that from
the average there's some some amount
that's more and the the blue will be
it's under less than less than the
average so it's more fluctuations that
we're seeing and not not raw values how
sensitive are the fluctuations you mean
how can you say a bit more on what you
mean by
Oh okay okay um okay I see now you mean
like how sensitive so so how much is it
fluctuating so you're kind of asking
okay so what are the raw values here so
I'm actually I'm not completely telling
the truth because we don't these aren't
even the fluctuations of the neutral
hydrogen it's it's a function of the
amount of fluctuation that gets into two
more astronomy details but but you can
say roughly it has to do with the the
column density and they're they're
details that I'm kind of putting under
the rug just for simplicity sake so if
if one is actually interested in how
much these fluctuations or I can talk to
you in more detail after this but um but
what you can imagine is just as the
lights traveling through the
intergalactic medium it's going to
either there's either going to be kind
of wisps of neutral hydrogen or not and
when you when you hit kind of some of
the wisps some of the some of the light
is absorbed but denser denser kind of
clouds of nutri hydrogen are going to
produce bigger dips but I don't I don't
have like the raw the raw numbers to
tell you unfortunately but um but those
are all interesting questions for sure
anything else about this map oh yeah go
ahead
Oh interesting yes so so why why did I
why is it cut out like this that is a
great question why for example is there
a little dip here and there and so forth
so so this isn't all the data from the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey but but what's
causing the the bizarre kind of shape
just has to do with where the telescope
is pointing and so on the Sloan Digital
Sky Survey points in particular regions
at different times of the year and so
the boundary is there's not going to be
a smooth boundary because it's going to
depend on where the quasars are so so
the for example right here the there
just weren't quasars near that part of
where the the telescope was pointing but
what also can happen for these weird
boundaries is that even if there are
quasars within that direction the
lyman-alpha forest could be such that
that that we either
so either the quasars could be too far
away or too close so that where the
Lyman howl lyman-alpha forest appears is
not within the the region the the
wavelengths that the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey is measuring so so it could be
red shifted off where the telescope is
is measuring data or it could not have
have reached that point either so so it
has to do with that the telescope design
so where it's pointing and also if if
there are quasars that quasars there or
not so yeah so there are some
interesting boundary boundary issues in
general there there are other pieces of
this that are just different directions
another problem that happens when
looking at the universe is I showed you
a picture of the Milky Way galaxy and
and so we're within the Milky Way and if
we were to look at the plane of the the
Milky Way we wouldn't be able to see
through the day
and so we're confined also by the fact
that we're in this spiral galaxy and so
we can only look above and below where
that spiral disk is so it's kind of kind
of interesting yeah oh yeah yeah ah yeah
yeah so that that's also a problem so
the question was what about the
atmosphere the atmosphere can absorb
light or kind of cause distortions so so
so yes that can happen the the so one
has to be careful that the portions of
the the spectra that we look at aren't
distorted by extra features due to due
to the atmosphere so that's definitely
something that we have to keep in mind
for ground-based telescopes
like the Sloan Digital Sky Survey some
are out in space like the Kepler
telescope out in space you don't have to
deal with the atmosphere issues but yeah
great questions certainly yeah yeah so
the redshift is if the source of the
light is moving away from us it gets
stretched and so the quasars are moving
away because the universe is expanding
at an accelerating rate so that's what's
redshifting it so if the if the source
was moving towards us then it would get
blue-shifted yep
yes yes oh yeah okay so so indeed
they're issued so the distances that
we're considering are so far away that
we wouldn't notice any backward and
forward motion with this data but if we
were looking at the nearer universe then
what can happen is objects for example
let's just use stars as an example stars
are sometimes you have binary star
systems and so you get these local
motions where stars are orbiting each
other and so at some point the star is
coming towards us so that would be
caused a blue shift and and sometimes
they're moving away so it causes a red
shift so so as a general problem when
you're dealing with the more local
universe those sorts of issues so those
we'd call Doppler shifts so those are
shifts due to the motions of the objects
when we're at these these very distant
distances local motions aren't going to
cause any problems anything else all
right so just then in conclusion what we
learned about today are that one trying
to figure out what's going on in the
distant universe so at higher redshift
is tricky because we can't see those
objects but that there are some objects
that we can see like quasars and so they
can help to give us the beginnings of a
picture of what's happening in the
regions that we can't see and so again
the quasars travel through the
intergalactic medium we see these
spectra the spectra have the lyman-alpha
forest imprinted and from that Lyman
awful forest we can get a sense of
what's going on along the line of sight
and then from those lines of sight we
can try to produce a picture of that
distant universe
and throughout the whole thing there are
different statistical methods that that
are involved that help us to to get this
this picture so I'm so I'll end there so
thank you so much for your attention
because we can't see or even though we
can't see a lot that's right is it
possible because of the time that's
taken the light to get us that when that
light was emitted they're just actually
wasn't as much out there uh-huh yeah so
the question is could it still be the
case that there are for example fewer
objects far away because it's an earlier
universe and and yes yet that certainly
that certainly could be the case we're
not we're not expecting a uniform
density of their distribution of
galaxies between us and and the very
early universe that's that's for sure
the the issue is just that we know due
to our telescopes that we are missing
some galaxies and so we just want to
make sure to to account for the fact
that some are missing due to the
inverse-square law of light yeah so
there's there's some magnitude
limitations yeah
yeah okay so when I was in Middle School
I was just fascinated by astronomy I
mapped the northern hemisphere star
constellations on my wall with the
glow-in-the-dark stickers like I just
thought space was really cool and then
in ninth grade I did a science fair
project theorizing the black hole
theorizing black holes as a center of
galaxies because that's when they're
realizing that black holes could be the
center of galaxies and I thought that
was neat but but then when I went to
college I I did a Bachelor of Science in
math and I for some reason didn't think
any more about astronomy other than I
was fascinated by it and I actually went
and worked as an as an actuary for two
years before going to do a PhD in
statistics at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill and and so still
I wasn't thinking about astronomy but as
I was pursuing my PhD in statistics
I saw a bulletin from the Institute of
mathematical statistics and in the cover
of that bulletin said statistics and
astronomy and I got tears in my eyes I
just was like oh my gosh of course
astronomy and statistics that makes so
much sense and so then I I started
trying to pursue that my dissertation
topic was already set but but I was able
to take some astronomy courses and then
my position after I finished my PhD was
at Carnegie Mellon and they have at
least five statisticians who work in
Astro statistics and I went there
because I wanted to get involved in it
and so that was a great place to to
learn about aster stat so I went from
being interested in astronomy to really
just pursuing math and then statistics
and then finally as a master's dad so
and also remind me in chemistry yeah so
in general I believe there are some
connections there were somebody's
connection but the overall what's the
direction for the statistics as a
subject to develop in the future okay so
the the direction of statistics in
general so statistics is actually quite
interesting because some there are some
who just are interested in the
mathematical properties of various
statistical methods and so statistics
has a very theoretical side it also gets
into too probability some probabilists
are in math departments but then you can
get to the very applied side of
statistics and get into data science and
and so these days this whole kind of
data science and push in the really
across the country in in various kind of
various areas has been making kind of a
presence in statistics so what you'll
find with statisticians is that many
statisticians have particular applied
fields of interest like for me I like
astronomy some get into neuroscience you
have biostatisticians who who deal with
tons of different problems in in biology
from kind of clinical trial type things
up to wealth like neuroscience even and
and genetics and and all of that so so
it does seem that there there are a lot
of statisticians who are getting
involved in more applied areas of
science so so we see that there's a lot
of discussion in the statistics
community about about data science even
just what is data science various people
have different perspectives status too
many statisticians will say well data
science is just statistics and then
computer scientists say well it's
computers
and send so many please Amy include
University the top of industries big
data big data yes yes yeah yes yeah yeah
so so big data is certainly a buzz word
maybe more than a buzz works it's it's
sticking around and it's probably going
to be around so so the the issue or
maybe we'd call it the opportunity is
that we're getting more and more data in
all these different areas so in a
Astronomy where various telescopes are
being commissioned that's going to bring
in just tons and tons of data every
night we don't know how to deal with all
that data and then you know like Google
and all these other kind of companies
that are gathering data on people that
use their products they get tons and
tons of data that they don't they need
ways to deal with it
so those are all problems that
statisticians are worried about computer
scientists are worried about machine
learning is kind of an area within
computer science they're they're
worrying about it so so these are all
challenges that we'll be around for
quite a while because I mean as we
continue along who knows if big data
will ever disappear it'll just get
bigger and so we'll just continue
needing more methods to to work with
massive amounts of data so yeah those
are those are definitely challenges not
not resolved
the way to million supergiant is such a
great question so the question is how
can we even see these objects that are
so far away we need
that's exactly right we need these super
giant magnifying glasses and and that is
what they have their their telescopes
and these telescopes act like what you
might imagine a big magnifying glass
would would act like and it's this this
telescope is reading in the light that
in the direction that it's pointing and
and so these instruments are sensitive
enough to be able to detect the the
various light sources and they can get
more light if they point at an object
for a longer amount of time so yeah
telescopes and engineering and how those
are designed are very interesting
problems and it's quite amazing that
they can even gather data from from so
far away yeah so you're you're are you
saying that these objects are so far
away and it takes a light so long to
reach us
yeah so these are such great questions
the so if you imagine that the distant
universe so the objects are billions of
light years away so if they started
emitting light billions and billions of
years ago that light has taken a long
time to travel to us so the light that
we see is actually really old light from
those objects so so we're not seeing the
objects as they are today we're seeing
them as they were billions of light
years away or like billions of years ago
yeah
so but but you also mentioned a really
interesting point and that is so we know
the Sun comes up and when the Sun comes
up we don't see those up the objects and
so so astronomers have to wait until the
Sun Goes Down to start reading in the
light and and so it also turns out that
whether there's a full moon or not
dictates how how good of data they can
get and so there are all these different
problems with scheduling one to observe
certain regions at the sky and certain
objects that that are related to the
points you just made so yeah so it's
it's a tricky problem but but
fortunately there are a number of
astronomers who are who out how to do it
so good questions come up and answer
another question 2 p.m. ok great
question so the question is how can we
see the Sun so easily but Mars we can't
really see that well there are several
there are several reasons I'm going to
go back to this picture this one so if
we see that the earth is here so we see
the size of the earth compared to the
size of the Sun right and then Mars is
is in here as well so the size of Mars
is so tiny that it's easy for us to see
the Sun because
so massive but but it's not just massive
it's it's very very bright and so
because it's bright and because it's
massive
we can see it very clearly but but Mars
is it's tiny
and and it's not bright it's not glowing
like how the Sun is glowing yeah yeah so
so yeah it's it's it's interesting just
because so the this is actually to scale
and so do you see how how big the Sun is
here right like so it's really big so
and very very bright so we can actually
see it extremely easily and Mars is is
much smaller and it doesn't glow and so
it's kind of like so if you're if you're
in the dark do you have any of like
glowing balls like where if you hold it
under the light and then you go into the
dark you see it glowing or yeah okay so
so with those glow-in-the-dark toys when
you're in the dark you can see them
right because it's glowing and it's easy
to see but if you just took a regular
tennis ball and it was dark you wouldn't
see it right so so because because the
Sun is glowing it's it's a it's actually
a lick it's a plasma and it's it helps
you know it shines but Mars doesn't
shine so it's not always going to be
easy for us to see Mars so yeah great
questions okay okay great
you